it's early morning and the new america
arm stores
is packed here all sorts of weapons are
on display from machine guns and
semi-automatic rifles
to the styling little revolver which
jennifer wen
always carries with her and it's very
small as you can see it fits in the palm
of my hand
and we wouldn't typically consider this
a caliber that you would use for
self-defense
you would want something more
substantial however a bullet is still a
bullet
and if this discharges to someone it
will cause damage and depending on the
shot placement it could cause lethal
harms americans purchased more than 17
million firearms in 2020
a record number the spike in sales
started during the coronavirus pandemic
and continued to rise during the black
lives matter protests
over racial injustice the november
election has further divided the country
with both republicans and democrats
suspicious of each other more than ever
there are those politicians
who basically if you boil it down really
want control
and so we know historically that
control cannot be achieved
without disarming a population there are
many examples of that worldwide and so
we're seeing
the extreme left want to
disarm the populace and the whole point
behind it is for control
that's the truth of it nobody wants to
admit that
robert lewis thinks this is a defining
moment in the history of the united
states
you can see already in american politics
that there's a shift
we have the the uh unreasonable
republicans that have
supported donald trump and and and now
they're kind of backing off
politely i can see the point
of the a lot of the people who were
opposed to it as to you know let's um
let's try to be unified and not divided
he wanted his children to witness how
different their city is these days
with its empty streets and barriers this
is a scene that's repeated across the
country the seat of the state government
shut down to the public and sealed off
and that's because the fbi has warned of
potentially
large-scale and violent demonstrations
but this is something
most americans have never lived through
before and it's causing a lot of
apprehension
one block away a bomb scare at the
virginia supreme court building
authorities sealed off the area but no
explosives were found
just an example of how the country is on
edge
the city council has banned firearms at
demonstrations
many say their rights are being stripped
away and vowed to rally in support of
the second amendment
in the days leading up to the
inauguration of joe biden
with the country deeply polarized the
image of public parks
and buildings closed is one of a nation
in fear of itself al jazeera
in richmond virginia